you don't know what I'm saying
happy
Wednesday everybody happy Wednesday or
as I like to call it at our house hump
day
but the wife makes amazing camel burgers
settle down
some news that'll make you spit Your oat
milk latte all over an orphan's face did
you know that muscular strong and
strapping men are perceived as more
conservative than wimpy scrawny skinny
dudes yep oh you do huh show's over
gotta go
true
true it seems that this
appears
appears to be more manly than this
no wonder he's out of work
and it's even before I open this
beautiful mouth
well now American researchers are
confirming what we suspected that
muscular physiques go hand in hand with
conservatism and if you're puny well
you're likely also a progressive
terrible language
but it makes sense check out how
left-wing these dudes are right huh
anyway
Ah that's probably a mistaken photo
us study participants were asked to
assess the political orientation of men
who varied in strength and muscle while
also considering various facets of what
constitutes conservatism and strong men
appeared more conservative than weaker
ones meanwhile the buff broad-shouldered
men are only seen as liberal
[Applause]
they're only seen as liberal when
they're changing in a woman's locker
room
[Applause]
not only that the perception that
muscles equal conservative was observed
regardless of whether the beliefs were
related to societal issues or economics
and it makes sense when you consider
what it takes to get those muscles
discipline hard work delayed
gratification extra protein all values
that would make a gender Studies major
report a hate crime
it makes sense conservatism is based on
incentives do this get that liberalism
is the opposite don't do anything it's
okay we gotcha so the left rewards bad
behavior and the right rewards good
behavior which is otherwise known as
effort this is why everyone in antifa
looks like a pilot
kick him
their their idea of Fitness is having a
piercing that's only mildly infected
with hepatitis
the study also found that people believe
strong men value their personal
Liberties more than weaker dudes should
but what does this mean for the rest of
us like say conservative liberty-minded
dudes who aren't as muscular as they
would like to be you know Jessie's about
as conservative as they get
but the only lifting he does is a
hairbrush
[Applause]
sea charm three times a day yet he's got
the upper body strength of cat tip
[Applause]
or what about fan favorite comedian Joe
Mackey over here ah look at that
all right
but a bundle of animal flesh
crawl all over him
but do people unfairly think he's a
liberal weakling because he has the face
of your aunt that never got married and
had 14 cats
coming on Joe it's sad every time he
goes for a walk in NYC he ends up upside
down with his legs sticking out of the
top of a trash can
people don't think he looks like a
liberal they just think he looks like a
lesbian
[Laughter]
thanks for coming on yeah
you should have seen the ones I cut
really bad but of course there's Tyrus
he could kick he could cook the crap
he could kick the crap out of the GOP
elephant himself is there any question
how he and his 38-inch neck votes
thanks Mom yeah
then there's cat Drew her arms are
mistaken for wishbones but
she says wiry is a short-haired Terrier
Tangled Up in a bali yarn
the point is there are exceptions just
look at Chris Cuomo if you can find him
his new show airs at midnight on the
closed circuit TV of a 7-Eleven in
Queens
now he's not conservative by any stretch
but check him out he built those muscles
and he built them through resistance
training mostly from women trying to
resist his advances
I'm kidding
I'm not
so even though participants in the study
all equated muscular physiques with
strong conservative values it's not
always the case right but at least in
the eyes of many it is so it's like my
uncle always told me you can judge a
book by its cover well unless it's
written by Brian Kilmeade
nerd
no I don't either this woman it's my mom
I know sorry but look
I know but look I know that
generalizations like this suck and it's
been my motto that one must favor
individuals over groups but my
impression of the truly fit is that
they're either apolitical or they are
right wing they're never outspoken
leftists so why can't people apply the
principles of Fitness to other aspects
of life if they know that it works
muscles get better depending on what you
put into them but that also it makes
sense would go for work education
security safety the Border economics
so if you love the gym you might try
that mentality mentality elsewhere
because it's not shocking that a lot of
people equate looking strong with
behaving strong as well so the next time
you need someone with strong values and
a strong jaw you know pick a TV host who
has broad shoulders and chiseled
physiques that you need
let's welcome
tonight
yes
his act has cleared more rooms than
President Biden's colon comedian Joe
Maggie
he's killed more fish than British
Petroleum Jeff chip I almost said Chief
chef and restaurant owner Andrew Grewal
she's like a Rubik's Cube difficult to
figure out and adored by nerds New York
Times best-selling author and Fox News
and he wants cartwheel to Australia New
York Times best-selling author comedian
and former NWA world champion Tyra
Pirates
Joe it's amazing I know I know I make
fun of you you do have washboard apps we
just can't see them
you're modest about your Fitness aren't
you you cover it up with
you know body stuff
why are you looking at me like that
Greg those insults were more Off the
Mark than Megan rapino penalty kick
Flex right now if I'd wax my masculine
back hair
but I'll tell you this I'm so
conservative that I use that to win
bodybuilding contests
instead of flexing I'm just like hey if
you uh get caught doing graffiti we cut
your arms off and then donate those to
the armless
[Laughter]
someone who's really fit uh also they
translate to a lot of different areas of
life even stand-up comedy the government
can't write jokes for you although uh
President Biden does does a lot of help
yes
yeah
not sure I'm a big fan of the super fit
comedians though no I mean I don't need
I need to be I need to laugh at somebody
not feel insecure I wish we were just
judged on our material yeah yeah well
that'll never happen with you
genius
who are misunderstood in their time they
will love him when he's dead
in about 2028
Andrew you are a world famous chef uh
does this apply in the kitchen like men
who can't cook are more right or more
left
yeah I mean men who can't cook are more
left I I we ask this when we hire people
so
and and finally you know you know what's
funny is is that when I actually heard
this study I went right to Reddit
because I wanted to understand the truth
behind this and I and and and and it's
true right so I on Reddit this was
brought up and somebody asked about it
and the overwhelming response and this
is fascinating is is that people who are
conservative are Vain and they only care
about themselves they don't think about
Equitable muscle distribution amino acid
distribution so it's incumbent upon me
as somebody who I feel is you know very
very open-minded to actually give most
of my muscles away yes so that's why I
used to look like Tyrus I was six eight
and like 290 a couple years ago uh at
post pandemic I've become open-hearted
now that's very sweet you did you have a
three pack now you used to have a
six-pack actually I used to have a keg
yeah
cat um okay you're married now you've
been married now for almost 10 years
congratulations
have you ever dated scrawny we
conservatives or jacked muscular
liberals or did it never enter the
picture no they were all scrotty and
weak oh really and none of them were
conservative conservative yeah they were
so skinny yeah that like we could share
clothes
which was
yeah when I met my husband my wardrobe
was cut in half
although you know who is really really
ripped you didn't mention like the most
ripped people are obviously like gay
Fitness influencers
that's why I said that they but they're
generally apolitical yeah who live in
West Hollywood and you look at them I
went to a I was invited to a gay brunch
in La once and I went and I had falsely
assumed there would be food there
silly of me in retrospect but I also
don't know how one gets muscles yeah
well it's easy you lift things why are
garbage men so buffed every day they're
lifting stuff up and they're putting it
down lift stuff up and putting it down
that's how you make build muscle so
become a garbage become a garbage man or
just pick things up a lot pick things up
you can do it you can do it around the
house you can lift up bottled water do
little workouts right I this is from my
experience working at Prevention
magazine these were the tips that I
would give I'm embarrassed right now
doing this
I'm just glad you didn't blow up but you
still got it
by the way gay brunch redundant
don't you feel gay Tyrus having brunch
it's Hollywood I feel gay every day I
guess uh
[Music]
[Applause]
because I I work out and in wrestling so
there's a lot of gay
and it's always been kind of the same
thing when the fitness guys they'll be
very quiet about who they are
politically because they don't want the
backlash so there's a lot more Jack to
gay conservatives than you realize for
not to get the the backlash it also
happens with a lot of brothers like that
too like it used to be like Cyrus
keep doing what you're doing do you want
to come on the show
yeah
you know but it's changing it's it's
changing now it's like a crosswalk yo
Tyrus keep it up dog I'm like all right
cool you talking about wrestling so but
here's the thing why is it a big deal
why are all the antifa guys look the way
they look and they only attack small
elderly women
Etc because they it's individual
achievement in the gym you also risk
failure and the audience that's watching
is you so if you bust your ass in the
gym and then you eat five pizzas on the
weekend when you show up on Monday
There's No Excuses when you're looking
at the mirror or your training you go
you have to understand that I was
feeling uh so many problems and I was
identifying as a fish and you can't
they're like what does that have to do
with the mirror and the scale yeah you
know it's it's facts based and so when
you get to that point when you work when
you get to a point where you're on a
consistent routine you keep track of
everything how much you spend on
training how much you spend on diet how
much you spend on this that whatever and
you have to look where your money goes
and that causes you to look when you get
your first checks and it's taxed like
nobody's business you're then going to
look to be like well how can I cut oh I
got to vote against these things so it's
it's a mindset it's the group because
everybody can be lazy and miserable in
the group
because they don't have to account to
anybody because they just expand the
group we see it a lot with what are the
most of the pronouns stuff they're
making new groups for themselves so they
don't have to explain
not succeeding with the group whereas a
guy in the gym or gal in the gym who's
working they'll see their results and
the truth is in if they factually put in
the work that's the difference between
the two groups and uh just to piggyback
on that when I'm at the gym and I I'm
often at the gym
uh that I've noticed that a lot of the
people that are into fitness also run
their own businesses yep you know it's
usually something out of a trunk but
but no I mean there's no but it starts
somewhere it's a free market it's a free
if you want to shoot your veins
anyway what I'm saying is they are they
are capitalists and they're capitalizing
on effort I think we killed this segment
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else